and minimalists hello everybody welcome
to the minimalist podcast where we
discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
Joshua Fields Milburn and I am Ryan
Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists welcome to episode 150 today
we're gonna talk about location and how
the place or the city or the town in
which you live affects the rest of your
life and it's one of those things that's
often overlooked or it's or it's over
overlooked meaning it's a either there's
often not enough an emphasis placed on
it or there's too much emphasis placed
on it for me I think about growing up in
Dayton Ohio and and now like looking
back at it it's one of my my favorite
cities we go back two or three times a
year and spend time there and there's
like create a crazy sort of positive and
nostalgia for me but also like there's a
familiarity but but there was also a
time when I wanted to leave Dayton and
placed a whole lot of emphasis on well
I'll just go yeah I remember I was
looking for jobs back and this was my
mid 20s my my boss was actually had an
interview with with a separate telecom
company and they were hiring I was a
regional manager at the time and they
were hiring regional managers for
different places and I was looking at
like I maybe I'll go to Providence Rhode
Island or maybe San Francisco's like
looking to get out somewhere yeah yeah
running to running away from something
as opposed to running to something yeah
and I think that'll be a common theme
because it's also important to figure
out what place is right for me based on
my activities my preferences right now
and that changes over time too and we
could talk about you know we've lived in
a few different places even though we're
in Los Angeles now we've tried out
different places and we've considered
moving different places before we get
into that though I just wanted to say
that they just announced the new iPhone
that came out right or that's coming out
are you gonna get it if you preorder it
it's the iPhone XS do you think they did
that on purpose
I don't know are they I realize a
million people have made the joke
already come on XS oh my goodness man
that's hilarious
that's funny man and then there's a
silver five well there's the iPhone
excess max which is even so they I guess
they had three different new models that
are coming out there's an XR which I
have no idea what that means but then
they're calling them 10 like 10 R and
then 10 s but really it's the XS and
then the excess excess max which is
exactly where we are in our culture with
Gonzaga
man what a yeah I I'm just wondering if
they they had to have known when they
when they're like yeah we're gonna call
this excess and the excess max like
their they had to see the irony in it
right I mean much much like I mean us
being the minimalist there's a lot of
irony and things that we do right like
we see it sure but maybe they maybe they
didn't see it so we just got back from
South Paulo yeah yeah I've got that on
our list of things to talk about during
right here right now oh okay if we are
to these questions first all right let's
go and get to the questions who's our
first question from Ryan it's Sarah from
Brooklyn well teaching is very much
aligned with my life mission I find that
a lot of my downtime spent that are sort
of recovering and resting and I seem I
feel quite depleted at the end of the
week I'm wondering if you can speak to
locations and because I'm thinking like
I feel that maybe in New York City is
not the right place for me how did you
decide on Montana and LA my other
question is I find that I keep
simplifying more and more and I wonder
does it become clear when you finally
reached enough or at some point do you
just say this is good because I find
that as I keep going deeper on this
journey I keep realizing I'll actually
need less stuff and it just feels like
maybe I've become a little bit obsessed
and my time is but too much sort of
finding into places to simplify so Ryan
she's a middle school teacher and she
talks about how that aligns with her
life's mission I think that
differentiation the the word she used
whether
intentional or not she said it aligns
with her life's mission but she didn't
say it was her life's mission and I
think that's that's a good she's
recognizing something that she has a
life's mission maybe that's to
contribute maybe that's to help kids but
there are different ways to do that and
maybe just maybe it has nothing to do
with a location that she's in she's in
New York City and but she's also it
sounds to me like an introvert like I am
I think it's perfectly okay it's fine to
be an introvert in the city although I
find a lot of introverts prefer to be in
crowded cities yeah I wonder like for
you who is you know high introvert what
is it about a tight tightly packed city
that makes you feel like you can still
be introverted all right yeah well and
why is it appealing I guess it's
appealing to me because well it's what I
call ambient people having access to
people and and and so the ability to
connect although there's another type of
introvert and they tend to be older men
living in Montana or Alaska where like
literally they'll live by themselves and
not see people for weeks at a time
they wouldn't yeah they would never live
in LA or New Yorker right right exactly
and they don't even want the potential
for interaction in fact that's what sort
of turns them away from cities is they
don't want that potential I want to be
bothered and well I don't necessarily
want to be bothered either I think I
have the right to be left alone I want I
want the ability to be able to to
connect with other people if need be and
that's one I've been one of the great
things about living in Los Angeles for
me is we have met so many new people
where I have access to them I don't have
to see them every single day but if I
have a friend who I have coffee with
once a quarter then that's great I have
that access a lot of people come through
here too which is really cool yeah yeah
is that that's a that's a great point
because you're living somewhere where
you have access to other people when
they come through here not a lot of
people were coming through Missoula
Montana when we lived there yeah I mean
occasionally and then of course we would
like spend time with them but it's so
weird I would always offer people to
come out to Missoula Montana which for
me like that's like if I was given the
option to go to Montana and had a place
to stay in the mountains like I would do
everything I could yeah to get out there
cuz I mean it is just like that's that's
my paradise you know yeah not many
people took me up on that offer right
but when I threw that offer in LA mm-hmm
dude it's funny cuz like within the
first two or three months I had to like
scale it back and be like oh like like
everyone's now taking me up on this
offer to stay at my place yeah you I'm
rescinding the offer right retro act but
I think of a lot of it has to do with
like people do just mean la is a hub so
people come here often Missoula is a is
a destination it's not really a hub of
sorts and in California but but Southern
California and in LA especially I mean
it's a world city right and so there's
something like 12 million people in the
county 20 million people in them in the
metro area so you can also find people
who align with what your preferences and
hobbies and everything I mean you've met
friends who you go surfing with now yeah
I don't have those same friends cuz I
don't I don't go surfing it's not that I
have any judgement against that person
but like it's it's in fact a good friend
of mine Andre you know Andre he went to
a comedy store with us
yes ago he's like hey do you and Becks
want to go out with me and and and my
girl for you know like a board game
night and I'm like no of course I don't
want to miserable right but but it's
also being honest about what my
preferences are and that's I think where
we are with Sarah right now is she is
being on she's starting to be honest
with herself about what her preferences
are I remember being in the corporate
world to make this analogous to what she
to her professional career when I was in
the corporate world I had I had to be an
extrovert almost all day right managing
people leading teams of people
interacting with customers no matter
what my role was even when I was just a
sort of frontline salesman in a retail
store all the way up to being a director
of a bunch of retail stores
I had to interact with people 24 hours a
day now part of that aligned with the
person I wanted to be because I did want
to lead people I wanted to help people I
wanted to add value to people's lives
and maybe 20% of what I was doing
allowed me to do that but the other 80%
did not
actually aligned with the person I
wanted to become and I think that's
where maybe Sarah is right now she it's
I don't know that it's the city it could
be the city and the only way you'll know
is to try out a different city doesn't
mean you do it for a long period of time
I just had our friend Nate Nate green is
moving I mean he he did that breakup
podcast with him
1:48 yeah and now he's he's been living
in Montana for you know a while and that
there in Portland he's like trying to
figure out like what's his next step and
so he and I did a living room
conversation together on YouTube
shout-out to YouTube audience hey you
know and when we were on living room
conversations he's testing something out
for the next year he's gonna he's moving
to he's moving somewhere overseas in
Asia and then he's going to Thailand
right yeah but a specific part where
there's a he's doing he's doing some
sort of meditation and it's close to a
particularly amazing man and then he's
he's probably gonna go to Croatia for
six months after that - and and then
after that he's not really sure where
he's going to be and I think that's the
nice thing so Sara asked how did you
choose Montana how did you choose Los
Angeles yeah it was it's funny man when
we went on that tour our very first tour
was what 2011 yeah at the end of the
year
and we did basically you know 75 the
highway 75 we went down to Florida and
then we you know Tennessee stuff that
you and I have seen a million times then
we started to branch out and go to like
Chicago or Phoenix or Portland or LA and
I just remember having that feeling that
you were talking about earlier before we
got any questions about how you just
want to run from Dayton Ohio because
well I think when you're raised
somewhere everything gets a little bit I
don't wanna say boring but you want a
change of scenery
yeah and Dayton Ohio you know the it is
a beautiful place don't get me wrong
but yeah I was like all right no more
cornfields you know no more allergies I
want to like get out and see some
awesome scenery or like being a cool
city right and every city we went to man
I was just like oh portland sauce
Portland you remember me like constantly
say every place no do we should move to
San Francisco if I was looking at and
this was back in what 2012 I was looking
or 20 year 2011-2012 I was looking at
places to live in San Francisco so I was
like okay that sounds good and I started
looking and it's like $4,000 for a
studio apartment and that was back then
it's even worse now yeah we just did
Kevin roses show and that's one of the
reasons he left San Francisco is like
the crazy skyrocketing prices of
everything and that's something else you
have to keep in mind she lives in
Brooklyn right now imagine how the cost
of living in New York City or were in LA
the cost of living here I was just
having this conversation with our friend
Amy from from Google or formerly from
from Google if you went to go work for a
non-profit but and one of the things you
have to keep in mind that the reason
that LA is a hard city to live in is
because the cost of living is
astronomical yeah
the the article I'd I just saw Richard
Florida I believe did the study and Sean
if I could find this I'll send it to you
and we could put it in the show notes
but Richard Florida did the study of how
much it costs for an apartment in Soho
in Manhattan you could buy over a
hundred houses in Toledo or Dayton it's
unbelievable the average house in in
Soho yeah the average person equals over
a hundred home average cost of wow
that's unbelievable homes that is humble
yeah yeah yeah I think you could do 70
in in Detroit and 100 and Youngstown I
mean it what was fascinating is cost of
living has to be has to play a major
factor and that was one of the the
things that allowed me to and we're
gonna talk about this I think with
Javier's question coming up next but but
the cost of living in Dayton allowed me
to pay off my debt it would have been
much harder in a city like Los Angeles
for me to become completely debt-free
because I by definition I'm gonna spend
more money on on just my bare essentials
all right keep it a roof over your head
keep yourself fed the average house in
Los Angeles not not just the nice places
like Silver Lake or
or Lowe's felis or West Hollywood or
Venice the average house in all of LA is
approaching $600,000 in god it's
unbelievable and and you know you go to
a place I date and you can get a nice
house for $60,000 not $600,000 in date
and we'll get you a mansion you know
maybe the the Beverly Hills equivalent
times two you've brought by to Beverly
Hills houses and in Dayton that's so
crazy you know it's funny like as we're
talking about this I'm asking myself
like why don't we move to LA again but
you know honestly man like because of
the podcast and the projects that we're
working on like this really is the place
to be right now for us right some
keywords right now yeah right now and
you know I look at it like an investment
mmm the the cost of living it is yes way
higher than most places in the US but I
don't look at it as like a waste of
money I don't look at it as like
anything other than an investment that
that Mariah and I not just with our
money but our time too
so it you know just to Sara's point like
she's got to look at you know when she
moves to another place is it yeah if she
needs to save some money great but
saving money isn't always the the right
reason to pick a place or not right
although I wouldn't have moved to LA if
we were in debt no and and because it
would be more difficult to pay off that
debt yeah so let's talk real quick about
so you sort of illuminate a why we moved
to LA it's a place where people go to
tell stories you want talk about Montana
first why we moved to Montana yeah yeah
that's that I think that's a better
starting voice over in Dayton Ohio we
did this 33 city tour with our first
book minimalism love a meaningful life I
wanted to move to every single city we
went to oh three three cities 32 others
it was dating and 32 other things but
yeah every time we're there I mean I
remember being in Knoxville and was
pretty happy yeah it was great Knoxville
right and and what I started to realize
is oh I can be happy anywhere yeah it's
we don't hate change we hate being
change
but when we implement change on our own
we actually look forward to that right
and that's what I looking at those
cities now if someone were to tell you
Ryan if all of a sudden you have been
told hey you have to move to Knoxville
you be like what why I'm like no but I
wouldn't like to be forced to move
anywhere exactly and so what we like is
our ability to have control over our own
change where people say I hate change I
think they're wrong because if their
bank account changes seven figures and
the positive all of a sudden they're
gonna be like yeah I like that chain
right well what we mean is we hate being
change we hate unexpected change we hate
changes that are thrust upon us so Sarah
is in a good position right now because
she's looking for elsewhere so if she
decides to stay in Brooklyn then she can
make that decision on her own so what
why did we move out to Montana man um
Missoula what yeah yeah so god man I
don't know where to start I mean I guess
how about this we were dry we were the
very end of the tour the thirty-third
city was Vancouver BC yeah we were
finishing it up driving through Montana
and before we got to Montana was it was
late and we were like you know we were
in Idaho we're like you know what we're
just gonna stop here in Idaho yeah
spend the night and then we're gonna get
up tomorrow and just like barrel through
Montana and get it and get it over with
we'd never been to Montana never never
never never even thought about Montana
yeah and then and then we stopped in
Coeur d'Alene Idaho and they'd you know
one of the charges like 250 bucks a
night for a hotel room which was crazy I
was like we're in the Panhandle I know
we're a little no way I'm like dude
there's no one in your parking lot right
now look I don't understand he did lower
it like I think you know was like 200
bucks or something yeah um but yeah he
was saying he was just telling me he's
like dude he's like there's a really
nice place he's like uh you know
basically trying to explain to me why I
was so expensive well when we woke up in
the morning and saw the beauty of Coeur
d'Alene it was like oh like this is why
it's 200 bucks a night because it's like
a very very gorgeous one of the most
gorgeous places that I've been to in
this country honestly and then we
started driving into Montana that
morning yeah and it was just I don't
want to say it was more beautiful or
less as much as it was just different
beauty around every corner for me it
literally was more beautiful I we were
in
and Idaho and as soon as you cross that
line in the Montana for some reason it's
like it's picturesque yeah and then we
hit that spot there's this tiny little
waterfall right off of i9 well before
that we stopped to get coffee in
Missoula and Missoula Montana and what
was crazy about Missoula was a we found
awesome coffee and we found awesome fish
tacos and like rest so those are two
things that when we go to a city that's
what we kind of consider is like how
good is the food yeah can you get some
decent food and you know not like
sit-down restaurant food but just like
they didn't have a triple Laila I mean
that's I mean they have one now but when
we first moved there they didn't have a
Chipotle that was almost a game breaker
or a you know game changer except they
had good fish tacos it's like all right
all right we can do fish tacos instead
of Japan yeah and then I remember just
going to oh no is it La Petite yeah yeah
La Petite I was like I forget the name
of the plate yeah went too late petite
Missoula Montana which by the way
awesome bakery awesome coffee if you're
in Missoula Montana definitely got a lot
late petite but I remember the barista
waiting on us and you know kids like I
have this like this inner hippie in me I
just remember like seeing the people
working there and like a they were so
nice student like that's the one thing
about Montana about Missoula is that
people don't look at me like I'm weird
like when I go up to someone hey how's
it going like they give me the same
energy back yeah
there's no like they there's not a
people don't have a lot of a lot of
walls up and in Missoula I feel like
yeah you go up to someone in Dayton Ohio
or Los Angeles hey I'm Ryan Nicodemus
and they're gonna look at you like are I
dude okay what do you want what's up
like you know like they'd be a little
bit trepidatious we're in Missoula you
go to someone hey I'm Ryan Nicodemus
they're like okay you're cool until you
prove me otherwise right so I so like I
loved that feeling but then also dude I
remember thinking to myself I could
probably find a drum circle here no I
never was in a drum circle actually
that's not true
Mariah's mom they do a couple drum
circles a year and I was like there was
one of them that I was and it was kind
of fun but but I you know for all
intents and purposes like I that was the
only drum circle was ever in in five
years so we left we we left late petit
we got our coffee we hit the road again
Ron I
and and then all of a sudden there's
this little waterfall off the side of
off the side of the highway and it
looked like someone was filming an
Abercrombie & Fitch ad it was like dudes
with raging six-packs like chicks and
thongs it wasn't it was skinny-dipping
right and so like there were six college
kids for women two men and they were
jumping into this little sort of hot
spring waterfall thing on the side of
the highway it's the first time my life
I've ever done a triple take and as I
looked over and this is not made up a
bald eagle flew overhead and the only
thing more American is if they would
have been like waving some sort of
American flag or the eagle had it in his
talons or something and and what I
realized like oh like this is what
advertisements try to affect is what's
going on right here in Montana today now
granted it was it was mid-july early
July of 2012 and which by the way is the
absolute perfect time oh yeah we got so
lucky when we were passing through
there's two solid months of weather
sometimes only one solid month of
weather a year in Montana and in
Missoula specifically and and it was
like the perfect time so gorgeous
weather 85 degrees skinny-dipping
beautiful college kids I've never seen a
bald eagle in my life I'm from Dayton
Ohio we don't have many bald eagles
there unless they're on the currency or
in a zoo right and so we sort of looked
at each other and you're like hey we
should come back out here to write the
next book yeah so for me it was the
community it was access to the the basic
preferences that I had yes good coffee
good fish tacos good pizza although I
don't meets anymore I miss pizza
especially the pineapple on it so anyway
what's different about Missoula I mean
you can get those things pretty much
anywhere you can go to Saskatoon and
find good coffee and and good people
yeah yeah so what I was getting to is uh
just the community in general that's
what really drew me to Missoula not only
that but sweeping mountains
awesome views and then you know kind of
totally romanticizing this
writer in a cabin yeah side of a
mountain which is what we did for months
we first moved out there was October 3rd
2012 I remember I arrived there a week
before you did and the day I got there
it was snowing and I'll be over yeah
early October do Mariah and I left for
LA in September and we drove her it was
snowing on the way it was like the last
snow anyway it was like Blizzard et I
mean and so getting there I'm like oh
this is different from what I remember
back in July and so we rented this cabin
in the middle of nowhere from Craigslist
and we just wrote and and and spent
those four months creating our book
everything that remains but then we
found ourselves gravitating toward
Missoula which was two hours away mm-hmm
we lived in this little you know it was
Phillipsburg Montana there's one traffic
light in in thirty four hundred square
miles but if you really wanted to go to
a city you either went to Butte or you
went to Missoula we found ourselves
gravitating toward Missoula and so the
end of that we decided hey let's
actually move to this city there's
70,000 people there it's it's not a
massive city but it feels much more like
a city because it's dense because it's
built in between those mountain ranges
yeah Colin also wanted to live with us
too yes well this is kind of what
spawned us really making this move Colin
was like man let's get together live
together for six months let's see what
kind of creations we can make and you
know we it was time for us to graduate
from from that small little town yeah so
we went into it only planning to be in
that cabin for four months and what see
let's see what's gonna happen we didn't
have a well let's move here for the rest
of our lives and I think that's quite
often the mentality we get into I and we
we get we it becomes much more difficult
to make a decision if the decision is I
have to make this decision and stick
with it for the rest of my life
it's way easier when you're like hey I'm
gonna give myself four months here
because you can do four months anywhere
right and yes Colin wanted to come out
because we were starting a publishing
house together asymmetrical press and so
we set up shop together the three of us
in Missoula Montana yeah
and then we ended up both meeting the
loves of our lives and in
Tanna and sticking around there for
about five years as a result I will say
this though you and I differ on Missoula
because for me I didn't find my
community there yeah and it was really
difficult I remember being like oh I
still feel this attachment to Dayton
because that was where my community was
and I was unable to find the the right
people for me in Missoula so um I guess
see I talk about what is uh what is
community to you meaning so for me when
I say community it's like I Missoula
Montana feel like the only place I could
ever live and accidentally fallen to the
main role of a play I mean I was at a
game night yeah and next thing I know
I'm like you know got the lead role in
this in this play and then I was able to
make some friends from there so for me
it's I guess it's acceptance really it's
like a community that I agree with that
so I never felt accepted in Missoula by
and large yeah there's obvious
differences let me I met Becks out there
yeah obviously I felt accepted by her
but and and by you and by a few other
people whom I met you know our friend
Nate Greene we met in in Missoula
Montana so there were there was a
handful of people but it was nice I
agree with you acceptance is part of it
I think preferences are another part of
it desires having similar desires as
people in the community and so I didn't
there weren't a lot of type threes you
know the Enneagram type three and
achievers in Missoula Montana oh I may
be I don't agree with that the reason
why I say that though is because one
thing about community for me too is how
involved are people in the community how
well do they treat their community and
Missoula is tight-knit not only that
there are some very very famous people
producers directors writers a you know
old talent agent like there's a ton of
talent in Missoula
well there aren't a ton of the people
there I think is the and so like it was
more difficult because I'm an introvert
and I spend way less time you know you
and I talked about the three the three
concentric circles of relationship you
have your primary relationships which
are like the five people were closer to
your immediate family loved ones
the the second layer your secondary
relationship so you're you're good
friends and extended family and the
third layer you're sort of you you can
either call it acquaintances or you can
call the the people on the periphery as
an introvert I have far more people and
that third tier on the periphery yeah
Vince can you do you have way more
people on the the second tier than I do
yeah like I've got I've got a list of
people who I never really got to develop
relationships with in Missoula and I
remember thinking like well not even
think it had happened where when I moved
to Missoula I you know had just called
five people that it was really close to
one would move away and then I was like
oh yes let me take it bring someone else
in but I really wanted to get to know
right and like I that list is still
pretty long yeah I mean so I would say
you know if Dunbar's number is 150 you
probably have a hundred people in that
second tier I have a hundred people 130
140 people in the third tier whereas I
have very few secondary relationships
you're either really close to me or I
can so call you a friend then we can
hang out once or twice a year but that's
that that's pretty much it for me I
prioritize my time alone first but when
I didn't want to spend time with people
I just didn't have that community of
people in Missoula it doesn't mean
they're wrong or I'm wrong I just there
wasn't it was a puzzle piece that didn't
fit yeah the one thing that you said
that stands out to me is is preferences
yes and like that's I think that's what
it comes down to because you know going
back to that introvert who lives in a
cabin in the middle of nowhere in Alaska
who would never live in New York or vice
versa like someone in New York may never
ever want to go out and live in that
cabin in the middle of nowhere it all
comes down to preferences yes absolutely
does so so I think when we're talking to
when we're talking to Sarah here she had
two questions one is about the location
she feels drained I don't think it's the
location that's draining her necessarily
it might be but I think it's her
profession that is draining her and and
it might mean that you have to figure
out what your mission is what's the
actual mission and then how do you
fulfill that based on your preferences
or your personality and it might mean
that you're helping children by writing
textbooks or children's books yeah and
that you you're spending most of your
time alone in doing that or it might
mean that you have to find a way to
two students one-on-one because it was
someone like me I'm much better
one-on-one whenever we go out as a group
like it's really difficult for me like I
get overwhelmed but if we just have a
sit-down one-on-one in fact Bex notices
the other day meet you and Mariah and
backs all went out to dinner right in
four of us yes went over to Takaya yes
and after our backs goes you and Ryan
are the only two people I know who can
just talk together forever and it's
because I have a guy I mean I can't even
do that with backs the way that I do it
with you it's cuz we know we've just
known each other for so long
exactly and we know what the other
person is going to say before they say
it quite often yeah and we come back we
have callbacks and little inside jokes
that are only funny to us but we think
they're really funny yeah yeah we swear
were the most hilarious people on earth
but how many times you gotta talk about
it doing a joke like with the podcast
something and you're like dude there's
only two people who would find that joke
funny it's still hyper specific yeah and
and so like you're like hey what about
mrs. cordini and I'm like they're not
gonna get that on the body
anyway shout out to mrs. cordini yeah
and so so when I what I learned about
you and I is like I'm so much better
when when like the four of us were
together it was sort of like you and I
siphoned ourselves off and we just had a
conversation because it's so much easier
for me to do that you do just as well or
maybe even better amongst a group of
people especially people you don't know
for me like I would just like I want to
leave immediately yeah so I've been
getting back to Sarah here though she
did sound I mean to me she sounded not
that she she really liked her profession
but that she was excited about her
profession mm-hmm
and you know it's funny you were saying
maybe it's a profession of the city when
I think about living in New York City
it's I get drained just thinking about I
agree I agree with that
New York seems overwhelming to me and
most like a lot of people who I talked
to who live in New York the biggest
complaint that I hear is how much you
have to work in order to afford to live
there so that could be a piece of it for
for Sarah here well that's the having
two versus one
getting to write yeah so it's like the
change thing where it's like you may
want a change and you then you accept it
but if you're forced into working
overtime just to pay the rent
yeah roach-infested well do arc apart
perfect example is you know we would
work you know 50 60 70 80 hour work
weeks yeah we there are some weeks where
we will work 50 60 70 80 hour work weeks
uh-huh it's definitely far and few
between you're saying then versus now
yeah I'm sorry yeah then versus now so
like now it's like we choose to do it
right late you're absolutely right like
if you were to tell me all right Ryan
all right dude like in order to make
this work we have to work 80 hours a
week from now on I would be like dude
like we have to reconsider but you know
if we are on tour uh-huh you know I mean
when we're on tour I mean we're pretty
much working all you know all day we get
to sleep at night yeah and you know 75%
of the nights we get you know eight
hours a chance to sleep eight hours but
25% we don't right but it is much
different like choosing to do that
rather than like you know yeah just like
having that being forced into well be
yeah being being in control is is part
of it and right now I sound to me like
what Sarah is dealing with she feels
like she's not in control that's why she
feels depleted so there there's a good
kind of tired and a bad kind of tired
right you go to the gym and you work out
really hard nicodemus lifts all the
weights all of them and then after we
gotta bring weights in from the back
afterwards though you feel like a good
kind of tired you you feel exhausted but
in a good way yeah now she feels
depleted in a bad way yeah and where she
doesn't feel like she has the adequate
time for recharging now if you leave the
gym you're like I'm exhausted I'm gonna
come back in 40 minutes
well all of a sudden be like then that
doesn't feel good you're gonna feel
depleted but when you come back 40
minutes later I have to lift these
weights again and so there's also that
time for recovery and that's why I
suspect she's an introvert I feel like
she's not getting enough time alone to
recharge on her own and then that leads
into her second question she says well
then I I feel like I'm over some
flying right I mean it do I ever get
there do I ever get to this minimalist
life no no I mean I don't think so I'm
almost there dude I'm so close what I've
realized is that yes you'll get
somewhere that you want it to be but
there's always gonna be somewhere else
you want to be and thank goodness for
that right like I feel really happy that
we're living here in Los Angeles now
we've got a beautiful studio set up I'm
really happy with the apartment that I
live in you know you're happy with your
new apartment that you're in and this
works really well for right now but it
does mean it doesn't mean that we won't
want to change some point in the future
yeah and circumstances are guaranteed to
change yes like there's that absolutely
so minimalism you know when I eat when I
first saw it it was never a destination
for me it was it was like this common
sense philosophy that I was like oh like
I just need to apply these principles to
my life and maybe I can regain some of
that control right
but yeah anything could be taken too far
right what yes yeah I think that if if
if it's reactionary the thing we were
talking about earlier we were doing the
YouTube pre-roll thing acting versus
reacting and maybe that's the question
that the Sarah is trying to figure out
here is if she reacting to the job but
does that make her want to move away or
is she wanting to take action because
that's the appropriate next step and in
her life yeah you know when it comes to
simplifying and her talking about how
she's kind of become addicted to it or
maybe she's like overdoing it you know
just to reiterate like you can take
anything and and overdo it she even
talks about you know she the word
obsession she used in her question
an obsession can be a really beautiful
thing
yeah really can be it until it becomes
compulsive right yeah yeah I mean in
fact you know I think that you
we often get confused and we think
removing the clutter is the end result
but you and I sometimes talk about how
it's really just the first step you're
you're getting rid of the excess so you
can make room for your health or your
finances or
your creativity or your career or your
ability to contribute you're making room
for those things that's the point that's
the purpose of simplifying there are
other benefits like it's nice you feel
calm in your own home it's nice to get
the excess stuff out of the way you feel
better coming home to an intentionally
curated home absolutely but that is not
the point just the the simplifying so
ask yourself why not just the how-to
side of things well the cool thing for
Sarah is so she has minimized her life
up to this point to the point where mate
you know she's talking about maybe she's
taking it too far but the cool thing is
is that if she does need to pick up and
move she could do that very easily
yeah and that's what I appreciate about
like Mariah and those possessions and
what we have in our lives as physical
things it's it's the right amount moving
always sucks but it's easier when you're
I can turn my life around on a dime it's
it's it's really does it's really
freeing the part of the reason you could
turn your life around on a dime is
because you're untethered from those
expectations as well where it's like
well now I'm gonna live here for the
rest of my life and I'm gonna have this
particular career for the rest of my
life and I'm going to have a family it
looks like this for the rest of my life
no you're not tethered to that you're
tethered you're untethered which is
freeing so that you can explore as your
preferences desires personality changes
over the years which it should yeah so I
think sarah should get clear on those
preferences and if she wants to leave
New York that's okay but instead of
running from New York she really has to
be clear on what she's running towards
so Sarah maybe it's time to graduate
from New York City and that's okay yeah
yeah I'm gone away you can go back if
you does you ever make the wrong
decision and that's the thing you and
and hopefully at the end of this I'm
gonna talk about some of my favorite
cities and why there's some of my
favorites and and what I'm realizing
with Sarah here is you're gonna make
some sort of decision you know and you
may not be the perfect decision but
whatever the decision is you're gonna
learn from it the important thing is to
take some sort of action to move beyond
the situation that's
comfortable right now and that's what
kept me where I was for a long time I
was sixty percent comfortable everything
was six out of ten it's like well I
don't want to feel any real pain I don't
want this to be a 2 or a negative 2 or a
negative 5 experience so I'm gonna stay
here in my comfort zone but after a time
that comfort zone becomes unsettling it
becomes uncomfortable because we're no
longer growing we're not being the best
version of ourselves and then what we
desire is no longer being that Sarah I'd
love to send you a copy of our book
everything that remains so Ryan and I in
that book we talk about life in Dayton
Ohio and we're paying off some of our
debts but also we talk about moving to
that cabin in the middle of nowhere and
there's a whole chapter about that
experience and then the the last chapter
in the book is actually about our move
to Missoula Montana and and then where
we're going to go from there there's
there's sort of the end of the book
talks about like being open to move into
these other locations location has
played a big part in our lives and and
of course it played a big part in that
book as well so Shana if you can reach
out to Sarah send her an audio book
version of everything that remains if
you like our podcast you like the
audiobook version or if you want the
book book or the e-book we'll send that
to you as well our next question is from
Xavier in Orlando I'm 42 years old I
have a wife and a seven-year-old son I
recently lost my job and I am one of
those guys who climb the corporate
ladder worked at a very very nice
corporate job as a director and making
well of the six figures and luckily for
me I lost my job because I've been
trying to follow my passion which is to
create and develop video games and I've
always wanted to pursue it but my debt
and my consumption always got in the way
so I have been trying to work with my my
spouse to be able to find a new way to
downsize take the equity in our house
pay off our bills we have a condo that's
$80,000 that we that we don't
that we would like to pay off it's my
mother-in-law's so we need to pay that
off
Elson has about 23,000 and that student
loan debt from getting my master's
degree in my four-year degree that I
would like to pay off and then I would
also like to put a good chunk down on a
house and finding a home for under
$300,000 is very difficult in our area I
know that downsizing to a smaller house
that fits what your needs are is the key
but what about the location because a
lot of times when you downsize you're
also downsizing the quality of your your
neighbors and your the location that
you're in and if you have children you
have to consider those things especially
with the school system so I want to hear
your thoughts on what would be the
recommendation for downsizing but also
taking into consideration the location
because you end up with a smaller
property you end up closer to people you
lose some of your privacy and a lot of
times you also have a lesser location
dude this is important to consider man
what that he's downsizing and yes you
know I think as a minimalist we're
trying to find the space that's most
appropriate for us right but if he's got
too big of a space but he didn't alluded
to that but I don't know that he said
that and that's I'm a little worried
here because he didn't allude to the
fact that his space was too big or
inappropriate for his I think it was
about expenses as what he was talking
about yeah so he's trying to save some
money so it is so important to consider
all these factors that he's talking
about when he's moving so right but I
disagree with with the the centum he
said I know that downsize I wrote this
down downsizing is the key downsizing is
not the key being debt-free is the key
for him right yeah and I think pursuing
the wrong thing if your pursuit is
downsizing you'll never have a small
enough house because you get into the
200 square foot house and you see
someone with 150 square foot house
that's the way it when he said
downsizing downsizing is key to me it
sounded like
ultimately what he was saying is is
downsizing is what it's gonna take for
me and my family to get to the
meaningful life that we want to get to
okay
so considering that yes like if you want
to live in Beverly Hills you're gonna
pay a premium now it's a nicer
neighborhood may be nicer school
district so forth and so on you move to
South Central it's gonna be a lot more
affordable not the best school district
however so there has to be a middle
ground there absolutely right yes and
and just because the cost of your house
he said if you're downsizing the size of
your house it means you might have to
move to a different neighborhood and
you're downsizing the quality of the
relationships in the neighborhood I
don't agree with that I mean I've lived
you and I grew up really poor and there
were great people and there were
terrible people living in our respective
neighborhood yeah and you know we are
fortunate enough now to now living in a
neighborhood like that however there are
so good people and bad people who live
in my building my apartment building
that we live in yeah and and and so I
think just because you're downsizing
your space doesn't mean that you
downsize the quality of your
relationship support well most of the
sort of middle-income places houses that
he's talking about you often improve
your relationship because you you become
you enter into a proximity of a
community of people who care about that
community well I mean the things that he
listed off he said you know smaller
property equality and neighbors school
system closer to people do some privacy
lesser location I mean those sounds like
those are preferences that are very very
important to him sure and my biggest
advice Javier is just like what Sarah
get clear on your preferences get clear
on your family's preferences that's
where you've got to start I mean it's
the same thing with you know where we
started with minimalism it was oh let's
get clear on what our actual priorities
are and now let's talk about how we can
act on these priorities and live in
meaningful life the same thing here is
where Javier needs to get clear on what
his preferences are and once he has
those uncovered then he can start
approaching neighborhoods and start
approaching houses and figuring out what
what is going to be within his price
range and he's going to compromise as
little preferences as possible I think
there's always a compromise like when I
think about Mariah nice new place hmm
our place is awesome dude one of the
best views I have seen in the city like
it's so freakin only view better that I
can think of is on top of the Netflix
building that one is awesome but the
neighborhood sucks like dude I was
telling Sean I was walking to work this
morning there was at least half a dozen
people just like sleeping on the street
and and it's not that I have anything he
gets homeless people but it just it just
tells the type of neighborhood that it's
in it's in Hollywood it's a bit rough
around the edges in Hollywood it's safe
I just have this realization the other
day like my life's probably not in
danger around here like I might get
heckled or someone might you know there
might be a crazy person like throwing
something at me but like it's really not
that dangerous but what I'm getting at
is is that Mariah and I we chose and we
discussed what are our preferences were
we have really you ranked them you
prioritize what your preferences are you
was huge for us like the view was like
number one or number two for me it
doesn't matter at all and so you have to
factor that in right yeah so the
neighborhood for us it was it was
obviously lower on the Preferences yeah
and for me it was much higher right I'm
one of the particular type of
walkability and and particular group of
people to be around a community yes like
I would definitely say the the I don't
want to say that the neighbors that we
have or lesser quality than the
neighbors that you have but you know to
to Javier's point like it is a different
there's a different community in
Hollywood a versus versus where you're
at yeah and yeah and so the the thing
that I wanted to say early on the Xavier
was congratulations for losing your job
sometimes we need to be pushed
sitting luckily I lost my job yeah dude
that is so awesome it's great framing
and III say bravo to you for that
however you have debt right now you
might have to find another job for
temporarily yeah man and I think that's
an important thing to realize it doesn't
mean you have to go back and be in the
corporate world for a long period of
time but you have to figure if your
outcome is to get out of debt then that
requires you're gonna have to do some
stuff that don't align with your
long-term vision but your long-term
vision is actually to live life
debt-free now you've got some other
stuff here you
he has $23,000 of student loans not that
big big of a deal on the grand scope of
things we have an $80,000 condo you said
it your mother-in-law's condo I don't
know idea what you're doing with that
but you know if you if you owe money on
that get rid of it if you have a a
rental property that that but you don't
actually own it the bank owns it find a
way to get rid of that because that is a
burden on you right now now that said it
could also be a blessing if it's paid
off and it's making you rental income
every month and yeah that is great but
you're not in a position to be in debt
for a rental property and so whatever
you have to do to get out of debt that
sounds like he wants to sell his house
he wants to sell this condo but you're
also gonna if that doesn't get you the
money you need to pay off a pay off your
house and put enough down on a smaller
house and pay off the rest of your debt
then you're gonna have to get a job for
a while and there's no shame in that
it's okay in fact there should be a lot
of pride and I'm working my butt off so
I can become debt-free and I'm never
gonna go back into debt again other than
this mortgage which by the way I'm gonna
hustle really hard to pay off this
mortgage to him man Xavier when you get
that free buddy that is like the sound
the sound of debt-free doesn't feel like
the feeling it gives you when you think
about being debt-free it's that the
feeling is so much better when you are
actually debt-free right like I thought
even more free than I thought I was
gonna feel being debt-free but you know
getting back to what you talked about
earlier he's got to find the middle
ground here
I mean if it's about saving money and
getting debt-free and if that's his
number one goal then move to Boone
County Kentucky go buy yourself a decent
out for twenty thousand bucks
pay off your debt now right probably
don't wanna move to Boone County
Kentucky but but that's why it's so
important to find this middle ground
yeah so when they're listen up
preferences what how do you prioritize
those meaning do you look at the top
five because you know from Mariah and I
think maybe we probably looked at the
top five but I guess you know you got
any advice on that when you go for yes I
think it requires the whole family
absolutely your son seven so I wouldn't
consider his preferences nearly as much
and in fact I think it's one of the
problems we often do is we over consider
our children's preferences and what hey
sweetheart what do you want
no here's what you're gonna eat for
dinner you're seven years old and I'm
gonna decide what because you're gonna
say you want you know pop-tarts or
whatever for dinner you don't get to
decide that yeah right so however you
want to keep your son's best interests
in mind when you're making it that's
part of decision and and someone who's
seven doesn't always have their own
long-term best interests in mind now I
think back to Dayton Ohio is a good
example it's not just the city it's the
neighborhood depending on what your
preferences are right like if I move
back to Dayton now I'd probably want to
move to a place like Oakwood because
their schools are an A and Dayton public
city schools are greater than the F and
and even though they're half a mile
apart yeah literally I mean you've got a
University of Dayton and you cross the
street you're in Oakwood but you're in
an a school district that would make
sense however last time I lived there I
didn't want to live in Oakland because I
wanted to be downtown right and so I had
the the schools did not play a role in
my my decision making and so schools are
gonna be uh are gonna be important for
you a walkability might be important for
you or it might not matter at all our
good friend TK TK Coleman he just moved
South Carolina from Los Angeles and
obviously he doesn't care about
hurricanes he's he's in Atlanta all the
hurricane by the way everyone in South
who lives in South Carolina here and
this is safe and sound and their friends
and family and stuff and anywhere in the
Carolinas in Shore but when he lives on
he's moving to like this I guess there's
an island there that you have you can
drive to it for me proximity to the
office is really important like we live
to it I love I love two and a half miles
from the studio right here and so I can
walk here if I want to or if I were
gonna drive here it takes me you know
just a less than 15 minutes to get here
right
however for him he wanted to be in a
neighborhood that he that worked well
for him he had the grocery he wanted he
want to be away from he want to be
really close to nature and wanted to be
away from the sort of hustle and bustle
of the city so he drives 30 to 45
minutes each way to work and back
because he doesn't mind the commute in
fact he enjoys the commute for him
because it allows him to listen audio
books while he
gives him some alone time for me if I
had I remember when I was well actually
here's a similar example when I got the
promotion I was working downtown
Cincinnati I still live downtown Dayton
and I made that fifty five mile drive
sometimes it would take me hour and a
half two hours to make it done
Cincinnati because I wanted to live in
Dayton / Cincinnati I had a I had a
preference there right and part of that
has to do with logically looking at
these things and saying okay here are my
hundred preferences fifty preferences
whatever they are write them all down
with the people in your household but
then also realize the logical side that
isn't gonna get you 100 percent of the
way there sometimes it's about how a
particular neighborhood or city or
community is going to make you feel it's
unquantifiable you just know you feel a
certain way when you're there so they
got a list of 50 preferences they can't
obviously honor all 50 preferences right
maybe they can't I'm not saying it's
impossible but probably not the right
expectation no and but then you
prioritize and you say what is most
important to me and so each of you picks
your top three here are the things that
really make the most sense Beck's and I
did our top five we had a list of the
things that are well here are ten
preferences now there were some overlap
for us as well and and realizing like
okay if you're getting this I may not
get this right but what is going to be
the thing that makes us most happy
together and realizing I know Beck's
what she really wanted to live like
close to the beach when we moved out
here but like we also realized we
weren't it wasn't a big enough
preference that we were gonna use it
that we were going to use the access to
the beach every day and by the way we
saw of access to the beach now I always
have to drive half an hour west to to
get there right and and and realize I'm
like oh just because it's right there
you live a block from the subway yeah I
don't know how often you use it well
yeah I've actually not been on it once
yet but I was thinking I was talking to
Mirai about this the other day we need
to get on there and just like ride the
subway for a day and gonna check it out
I mean I've got it takes an hour and a
half early hour and 20 minutes to get to
Santa Monica from the subway I could
drive there in like 30 45 minutes exact
traffic yeah because you have to
you have to go downtown in order to get
transfer my point is it sounds really
good when you move there but if that it
oh yeah if that becomes your decision
for moving there we can justify anything
we started to say well yeah it's really
close to the subway that's why I move in
there and then all of a sudden it's like
yeah I use it once a week right wait a
minute oh now for me walkability is
something that is most important I walk
places every day I go often you know we
were talking about this before the
podcast I'll go three four or five days
without using my car yeah sometimes a
week without using my car and and and
that's why that was something that was
like top on my list great weather which
you're gonna get pretty much anywhere in
Los Angeles was was part of the thing on
my list in fact it was one of the big
boomers for me living in Missoula is I'm
really affected by sort of like seasonal
it cause depression or seasonal grayness
yeah yeah and Missoula gets really gray
in the winter snowy and grape yeah and
it's very Pacific Northwest plus snow
and and so there's like this nine month
period where you have to deal with
winter and it it definitely affected my
mood because I wasn't able to walk a lot
outside I'd have to go to the gym and
just walk around the track for hours at
a time right and it was just not
appropriate for me and the summer was
great yeah it was really great but after
that it was like oh like this isn't this
doesn't match my preferences so if we're
if we're talking to Xavier here and I
think you have to get really clear on
what if you and your wife sit down and
say okay there's there's the three of us
my wife our seven-year-old son and me
what does my ideal neighborhood look
like is it in Orlando it may or may not
be you might love your community there
in Orlando it may be somewhere else you
might move over to st. Petersburg
because you're like I really like how
how great it is over there st. Augustine
or your or maybe you go somewhere else
all to go maybe you go to Dayton Ohio
because the cost of living is so cheap
there and you can buy the way you can
design video games from anywhere in the
world or maybe there's a place like LA
or elsewhere where there's this big
video game design community
and it makes sense to have proximity to
those people it's one of the reasons we
we came to Los Angeles we wanted
proximity to in LA
you get proximity to people this is
where entertainment is where people go
to make movies and tell stories and be
on our podcast we have access to more
people here than we did in Missoula
Montana or somewhere else
yeah dude and I cannot agree with you I
cannot agree with you more about just
because the neighborhood is less
expensive that you're gonna have like a
less quality of neighbors in fact
thinking about that likes in the nicer
neighborhoods you actually might have
worst neighbors you know what I'm saying
later oh you can have good or bad
neighbors a matter where you go how do
you define good and bad right exactly
what does a good neighbor look like to
you because I was gonna talk to talk
about this during the add value but I
sent you that documentary I don't know
if you saw it yet on tamadate Ohio it's
called Left Behind America and I know a
lot of people all of my friends and
Dayton aren't very happy with the way
frontline portrayed the city right
because there's a lot of despair in this
documentary we'll put a link to it in
the show notes but it shows the despair
side of Dayton in particularly west
Dayton where we're trying to build the
the grocery store there there's not 40%
of the of Dayton's population lives on
the west side there's not a single
grocery store in the entire west side of
them and and but there's also a whole
bunch of drug overdoses going on in
Dayton there's a whole like overdose
police force helping people out because
there's an opioid epidemic there a lot
of it had to do with the fact that
people a lot of people lost their jobs
there when GM left and they're very
physical jobs so very physical jobs
often lead to back pain or shoulder pain
or knee pain ankle pain whatever and so
they were prescribed a lot of opioids
during you know the this period of time
and then you lose your job you lose your
insurance and then you can't afford the
prescription drugs and people are often
turning to heroin and there's a whole
bunch of overdoses because there's
fentanyl mixed in with the heroin now
and and there's a huge like drug problem
going on all across America I mean
Dayton is just like buffalo or Rochester
or Akron or Toledo or or any of these
other cities where a lot of
manufacturing base was was established
and then people lost their job
but what the documentary didn't show it
showed a little bit of the hope at the
very end there's like five to ten
minutes of oh there's actually hope here
because there are people in the
community in West Dayton one of the the
poorest neighborhoods in the country
yeah there are people over there that
are that that are working on a solution
there's outstanding people in this
outstanding city they're trying to build
a grocery store there's whole just so
much revitalization going on I mean they
didn't show that piece they they shine
the light on the problems and gave you a
little bit of hope but to me it's 50/50
I saw real hope there because of the
community because the people are working
together you and I have worked together
the House of bread and Dayton a bunch of
times yeah and you realize like these
people who were volunteering here people
were making twenty five thousand dollars
a year
mm-hmm they're not rich right and there
are other people who are making two
hundred fifty thousand dollars a year
who are also volunteering right next to
them yeah because they have a common
objective and it's helping the people in
their community and so ultimately the
question is how are you going to find a
community in which you can participate
now participating might mean working in
a soup kitchen yeah it might mean doing
Habitat for Humanity or it might mean
just going and having game night with
the other people in your community if
that's something you want to do what
does participation look like in in in
your plan here all right well uh Xavier
I would love to send you a copy of our
book essential it's sa collection with a
hundred and fifty different essays in it
there's twelve different chapters and
there's a chapter about downsizing in
there it's called stuff this name of the
chapter eleven arms are twelve different
areas of living and intentional life are
outlined in that book so Sean if you
could send Xavier a copy of essential is
the audiobook the e-book or the book
book I would appreciate it and of course
we'd love to hear what you all have to
say so if you have a comment or a tip
about well the city you live in or the
location you're moving to including
advice for any of our callers today
leave us a voicemail for zero six two
one nine seven eight three nine you can
also email a voice memo to podcast at
the minimalists comm or air our favorite
common
and tips on a future episode and stay
tuned to the end of this episode for
this week's listener comments and tips
Ryan what time is it it's time for our
lightning round where we answer
questions from the social medias indeed
run Twitter Facebook and Instagram at
the minimalists during the lightning
round so Ryan and I each do our best to
answer every question with just a short
shareable lesson 140 character response
we'll also put the text of those minimal
Maxim's in the show notes so you can
copy and share our pit the answers on
social media if you'd like and now you
can find all of our quotes in one place
minimal maxims calm our first question
is from Shane Shane Wrightson why are
some places happier than others for
example why is Denmark happier overall
happier than the US well I mean so I
have a pithy answer that I'll share in a
second but then mark itself isn't happy
it is an inanimate state in an inanimate
piece of land with borders drawn around
it right and so the people in Denmark
are on average happier based on some
fairly subjective surveys as well right
happiness is obviously subjective right
so my pit the answer though and keep
this in mind my pithy answer is don't
mistake others happiness for your own
and and I think first you look at some
of the the happiest countries there are
some of the safest countries yeah but
then also the least happy countries are
often the least safe country you look at
places like Chad it's one of the most
unhappy places on earth because it's so
dangerous or South Sudan well very
dangerous so it's hard to be happy when
your life is in danger all day right
yeah however some of the least happy
countries are also countries like
Luxembourg which makes the most money
per capita in the entire world least
happy country least developed country
least happy developed country is
Luxembourg hmm now so there is a certain
level of safety that lends itself to
happiness flourishing but beyond that
more money isn't going to make you safer
or happier or more content in fact
can make you more isolated and that's
what I think you're seeing in a place
like Luxembourg if you feel a more
isolated you might feel less happy and
so when I look at that the happiness of
a place I don't want to confuse my
happiness for someone else's happiness
you and I could go live in Edmonton in
fact I'd love to live in Edmonton as a
Nazca tun yes so these are these are
goods I could be happy there regardless
of whether or not that that most people
will identify that place with happiness
and also I could move to Denmark and be
miserable a lot of that has to do with
my own mindset yeah it's I think being
around happy people is gonna make
someone it's gonna give them the chance
to be happier but it doesn't guarantee
someone's happiness yeah so just you
know just kind of adding to your point
about don't mistake other people's
happiness for your own I mean that's why
it's like if you're a miserable
depressed person move it you might just
actually make everyone else unhappy
around you if you move to the where
everyone's happy I mean it's rose its
possibility but I do understand that yes
the more happy people you hang around
then the more of a chance you have to to
be happy I guess I mean I could see that
correlation to my pet the answer is the
more we contribute to our community the
happier we make our community dude this
for me going back to Missoula that is
why going back to the drum circle thing
then like that is it's not that the
actual drum circle as much as it was the
community was so I felt like it was very
welcoming and I remember hanging out at
the top hat shut up to the top hat of
Missoula we're out back there's like a
little concert venue you've been there
oh yeah
Sean's been there Podcast Sean's been
there we were out back on the patio and
I was just like having a beer and I was
talking to someone out there it's I'd
probably lived in we just moved there
probably a month I'd been there and I
was just talking to someone about how
awesome Missoula was I was like dude I
know you know I'm telling him everything
that I told you the you know the story
about La Petite the waterfall the little
hot warm springs uh you know how awesome
the community is and he's like dude he
said the reason why this community works
is because everyone has to be that way
if people aren't go out of their way to
be accepting if people don't go out of
their way to contribute to the community
well then this doesn't work and the only
reason it works is because everyone
contributes so we can buy by
contributing to our community I mean
maybe it's just like a fraction but we
do make a happier community it's the
same conversation I was having with Amy
about about the cost of living in place
like la also Dayton doesn't even though
for all its struggles with lack of food
lack of what the opioid problem you know
the underemployment or unemployment
problem there are problems there there
also isn't much of a homeless problem
there isn't a significant homeless
problem because the cost of living is
way cheaper in a place like Dayton you
go to downtown Los Angeles you go to
Skid Row and you're faced with a
significant homeless problem maybe
there's ninety thousand homeless people
in Los Angeles and a big big chunk of
the reason why has to do with the
housing affordability and the way to in
LA is pretty nice yeah absolutely but
but you have you go to a place that has
higher homelessness there there's there
several studies out there now that will
show you it often has to do with the the
public policies for keeping housing
really high the expense of housing is is
a key factor in the amount of
homelessness that happens in us in a
city and so it's I mean that's some of
them worth keeping in mind I look at
again that that goes back to the
dangerous thing if you're if you're
obviously if you're you're homeless or
you're not living in a place that you
feel safe mm-hmm
then it's going to affect your happiness
beyond that though meeting the the basic
requirements for for your own safety and
certainty it has a lot more to do with
being steeped in a community that is
willing to help each other out
yeah I could not agree more all right
Valerie wants to know when selecting a
place to live
how important are transportation options
well my short answer to that is to get
one oh if we can't own a Lamborghini
then we ain't move in there
I didn't write that down Oh to get where
you're going you must have a way to get
there is yeah I mean it that's that's my
pithy answer it transportation and
depends on what you mean by
transportation I own a car that is
transportation I have two legs
thankfully and that allows me to walk a
bunch of place I want to walk and so for
me having access being in a centrally
located neighborhood was something that
was important to me public transit and a
lot of in a lot of cities like
especially Los Angeles a public transit
is not great there are other cities like
New York City where public transit is
truly outstanding if you want to get
somewhere it's gonna make less sense for
you to own a car if you're living in
Manhattan then if you're living in Los
Angeles however in a place like Los
Angeles it's 88 different municipalities
in LA County you can walk a lot of LA's
is actually very walkable as long as
you're not trying to go from Pasadena to
Venice all right
even then public transit you can do that
you can get from Venice to Pasadena take
a bus up to Santa Monica
then you take a line downtown you go
from downtown up to Pasadena but it's
also gonna and I've done this with with
Ella it's gonna take you two and a half
hours probably yeah to get out there and
so you have to keep that in mind where
are you going and then living in
proximity to that is also pretty helpful
yeah the vehicle we regularly use is it
nearly as important as sticking to our
budget so ultimately for me man it
doesn't matter
I prefer public transit we don't have
awesome public transit in LA so I used
my car more than public transit I mean
I've used I've used the bus system a
couple times but like you know I would
prefer a system like Portland like
Portland's got this awesome public
transit system right that would be ideal
for me however you can always get that
you can't always you know get your
number one preference so for me it's not
about moving to a city where they have
to have this awesome public transit as
much as it's like am I gonna be able to
get from point A to point B without
going into debt that's really what it
comes down to and can I afford it right
and or if public transit is your number
one preference then be honest with
yourself about that right if that is the
the number one way you want to get round
around and that's really important to
you then consider that closely
when you're like--okay short commute for
me is a big preference right having
access to to walkability is a big
preference for me but that may not be
your preference so just asking the
blanket question how important are the
transportation options that's a question
I would actually put back on Valerie
here is how important are they to you
when I look at TK Coleman he would
rather drive 45 minutes and live in the
neighborhood in which he wants to live
then live really close to the office and
not live somewhere he wants to live a PS
Ryan we have one more question that
question is from Gary Gary asks what is
it about turning 40 years old that makes
me want to throw away all my stuff sell
my house and move to literally any other
city
I can definitely resonate with this but
if you want to hear our answer to that
question you can listen to this week's
PostScript episode over at the
minimalists private podcast available
exclusively to our patreon supporters so
if you want to support our show and keep
this podcast 100% advertisement free
then head on over to the minimalists com
a slash support in addition to our
weekly PostScript episodes the
minimalist private podcast feed includes
our monthly ask the minimalist anything
episodes unreleased recordings of our
live events and the entire back
catalogue of past private episodes and
once you become a supporter you'll
receive a personal link to our private
podcast feed so that it plays right
there and your normal podcast player you
can find all the details and all the
good stuff over at the minimalists com
slash support and here is a snippet from
this week's PostScript episode
[Music]
it was just running away from something
and and I think that's what it is it's
wanting to change our geography we think
that's going to change the situation
we're in but unless we fix the situation
that we're in changing the geography is
probably just gonna get you right back
into that same situation maybe even
worse because you're no longer
surrounded by any of the support group
that you had previously all right Ryan
that was time for our added value
portion of the show so we each talk
about something that has added value to
our lives
recently I was gonna talk about why I
wanted to talk about that that
documentary
first and foremost like that the Left
Behind America like it left an impact on
me I shared it with some friends and I
started it it makes it's really
difficult for me to get me to tear up
about anything but like you could see a
community that truly cares mm-hmm and I
get some of the complaints from the
documentary especially if you live in
Dayton it makes the city look way worse
than it actually is but the other
problem can also be true like you and I
heard go make a documentary about the
city of Dayton and make it look super
super rosy yeah because I am I am a
raving fan when it comes to Dayton Ohio
yeah I could just show you all the
really cool stuff the world's largest
claw over at a proto build bar that you
know I'm talking about yeah it's five
bucks to play the claw game right
I mean ty9 press coffee press coffee
house best coffeehouse in Ohio one of
the best and the entire country press
coffeehouse they just open up a second
location they're working on a second
look get out of here Belmont
congratula man if they're listening this
congratulations guys that's awesome yeah
and so press has opened up a second
location ty nine is the best Thai food
in the country the Air Force Base is
there I mean I'm the Air Force Museum
yeah the base is there too well yeah you
can't really get on the base unless you
have clearance but yeah I was born there
I snuck in used to actually manage a
retail store at the Air Force Base did
you ever go to that one
I never was there yeah we had therefore
it was temporary right less than a year
yeah so yeah but it was a really strange
thing like the base has its own
shopping mall nearly four employees yeah
it's really well but yes I manage a
retail store up there so I had I had
clearance to get on they make you do a
whole background check and everything
but um so so Dayton Ohio has a lot to
recommend it so I could show you that
side of of Dayton or I could show you
what the the downtrodden side and but
guess what I could do that with LA I
could do that with Philadelphia yeah we
were just talking about that in Sao
Paulo it's like people were trying to
scare us so much that we're trying to
scare us they were just trying to make
sure we were safe sure to the point
where I was I started to get trepidation
like just to walk down the street and
then I'd let you know totally push
through that because that's what I do
and then Sean are walking around and I'm
like walking around like dude this is
just like LA it's like they're her
places you go and you don't go yeah
there are places that are perfectly safe
at night and then there are places you
wouldn't even dare go at night in the
same city and absolutely
that's how Dayton Ohio is that's how Los
Angeles is San Francisco everywhere else
I mean you go pretty much anywhere
mm-hmm and you're going to find that and
and finding what is appropriate for you
is going to be different also depending
on where you are in life now I can tell
you that that documentary it really
shined the light on the need for some
change also the people who have been
left behind do you think maybe the
documentary was so I want to say harsh
but that's not the right word but just
for the sake of keeping this
conversation going what do you think the
documentary was so harsh towards Dayton
Ohio to really call to attention how
much help people need and and not not
just in Dayton but you know you think
about places like Detroit I mean there
are a lot of cities where you've got
this downtrodden they've got drug
problems they've got poverty they've got
crime and minoo personally I feel like
that we do need to do something we are I
mean we're trying to help gem city build
their grocery store there right so do
you think maybe they heavy-handed it
maybe that's the right word a
heavy-handed the bad side of Dayton
because they wanted to really motivate
people to help
III think so yeah and I mean and that's
why I get it like I was talking about
friend Mike about this and he was like
yeah because I was like look Dayton's
beautiful there's all these Revital
revitalizing efforts throughout the city
but also there is this other side
and I saw a lot of hope in that despair
yeah and he goes well yeah you and I
know what's going on in Dayton but to
the outside person this isn't gonna make
someone want to move here no well that's
not the point of the documentary right
it although for me it actually did I I
saw it I'm like I want to help ya be in
and I don't have to move there to help
but but I mean we're hoping now with
like we just talked about with the Jim
City thing yeah yeah and and so it made
me actually not want to not be
complacent and it should spur some
people in action and to answer your
question I think what they were trying
to show Dayton is middle America
although in the early 1900's it was
Silicon Valley yeah Dayton had more
patents per capita you know NCR was
there the Wright brothers are there
there was a thriving community of people
in the in the first half of the 20th
century where it was the Silicon Valley
it was it was the hub of American
innovation yeah and it's not that
anymore but it also shows you that this
booming place just like Silicon Valley
is now that can have a downturn that
that any place even though it's thriving
right now can have a downturn yeah dude
it's it's just funny too because I think
there's something to be said about
complacency too like when I think about
the the arcade for example like that was
eight market yeah the Dayton arcade it
was predicated off of consumerism and
you know when I when I think about that
that that empty building that we were in
it was a representation of what happens
when you focus only on consumerism
well what's fascinating about that is it
actually it started as a community hub
and that's when it thrived right right
and then it turned it yeah and then it's
and consumerism exactly so I think the
same thing I'm trying to get at is with
complacency when you are you know the
have the most patents you're the Silicon
Valley of your day like you start to
become complacent
and you start to just look in the mirror
and say yep we're awesome more awesome
more awesome and then it's awesome until
it isn't yeah in fact they had the mayor
in this documentary the guy who was
mayor if I think from 82 to 86 and what
my friend one of my friends told me it
was like yeah he's basically one of the
people who presided over the downturn
and didn't do anything about it because
there were people in the community were
being complacent and one of the lines
that the mayor said was we thought in CR
would be here forever and we're still
upset about it it's like well the
problem is became complacent you became
complain you assumed that everything was
gonna stay the same yes for all eternity
what a I'm sorry what a bad leader yes
like that's horrible oh absolutely so
what the thing I wanted to talk about
Ryan was my five favorite cities we've
been all over the the we've been all
over the world but my five favorite
cities in well North America I have I
have them written down here we can talk
about each of them briefly but part of
it has to do with the way a place makes
me feel when I go there like you said we
went on that first tour and yeah every
city I go to I really would like to live
in Kansas City this is really great but
after looking at it sort of objectively
and subjectively my five favorite cities
are Oakland because it reminds me of
Dayton but with really nice weather and
there it's it's nice and walkable it's
crazy expensive now it wasn't always
that way but because San Francisco so
expensive Oakland has become ten years
ago people were not saying let's move to
Oakland no no it's like wow yeah yeah we
can afford it let's move to Oakland
right Tucson I love Tucson fact almost
moved there in 2014 because we we were
there on tour and we were doing this
book in fact it's in our documentary
minimalism but there was just I don't
know what I can describe Tucson is it
made me feel unlike any city I had ever
made me feel up to that point and I have
found some good people in the community
even though we were there for less than
a week like I remember like oh this is a
place that feels right to me and I
couldn't necessarily give you a list and
compare that to other cities and say
well here are the 10 reasons that Tucson
is my favorite city
and no it just it made me feel a
particular way right and maybe want to
go back there's I've only been back
there once but since then but I just
remember leaving there with with a great
feeling a Salt Lake City you and I've
been there a bunch of times because it
was one of the city like more and more
every time I go I think it's so well
it's it's so intentionally planned right
yeah and when it was built up to all the
mid-century modern architecture the way
the streets are planned they're all 660
feet the Wow
each block is of course you tall jazz
are there so I'm a big fan yeah they're
poised ever really good season this year
but uh there's just something about Salt
Lake as well that you go there and the
mountains are so gorgeous the Salt Lake
itself is gorgeous right outside they're
awesome awesome community amazing people
great coffee shops and there's like this
interesting because the Church of Latter
day Saints is there but there's also
like this counterculture of people who
get along with those people who happen
to not be Mormons and it makes for this
interesting dynamic because not everyone
is the same there but everyone tends to
share similar values even though they
might have different different beliefs
so Salt Lake City is a great City Los
Angeles this is where we live right now
and and I I really enjoy living here the
weather is amazing
I found pockets of people who are truly
amazing it took a while to find those
people because you're sifting through
the thing about LA is you can have
whatever you want
it has everything but you have to really
be clear on what you want and then once
you get clear on what you want you have
to go out and find it to find it and
it's so figuring out what you want that
that's hard that's a hard task in itself
and then going out and finding those
those pockets of people like that's even
more difficult but dude I totally agree
like once you find your peeps in LA yeah
in like your communities like it's yeah
it's one of my favorite places and then
Dayton Ohio that's that's in my top 5 as
well and part of that has to do with the
familiarity we talked about part of it
has to do with this lack of pretense
it's a blue-collar City and there's very
little pretentiousness in in the city
and like I feel about date in the same
way you felt about Missoula when
they're like you found you were able to
connect easily with the people and I've
always been able to connect easily with
the people of Dayton yeah and some
honorable mentions for me Fargo San
Antonio st. Petersburg Florida Edmonton
and in San Diego those were all five
cities where the I don't know that I
would ever live there necessarily but I
know that I would thrive in any of those
those five cities yeah what about you
Ryan
I've got like two cities Missoula and LA
yeah two places I want to live there you
go I could I could live in like he said
I could live anywhere be happy but like
my preference I mean so far like
missable in LA by far I think of my two
favorite cities um yeah I mean talking
about all these cities I know people are
like yeah that's great if I could afford
to go to these cities how can I get to
these cities if I'm on a tight budget
well let me tell you how this podcast is
brought I'm just kidding it's not
brought to you by anyone but I am gonna
recommend a Skyscanner
I think it's dot-com or maybe it's done
it I don't know Shawn I'll have it in
the shown its podcast podcast I'll put
that in the show notes
um Skyscanner is basically a app or a
company it's kind of like kayak but what
you can do is you can say hey I got a
vacation from January 1st to January
14th and then you just pick those dates
and then you could just click an option
to go anywhere in the world and then it
just starts to show you all these
affordable options okay it is if you if
you can use so I have a friend who like
you know she just loves like the travel
hacking stuff right yeah she's really
good at it but if you if you Skyscanner
and you accompany that with like
couchsurfing I mean I've seen her go on
trips to India and not spend more than
you know 400 bucks or 500 bucks so is it
easy to like go on these long vacations
super cheap again no like nothing in
life worth doing is generally easy but
you put some work into it watch some
prices get out get on couchsurfing and
you know make some friends in the
community and you could you could almost
anywhere in the world and not have to
spend you know a thousand two thousand
three thousand whatever it may be it's
so funny dude like when I see on the
prices
right or like wheel of fortune which I
haven't watched in forever but I just
remember like they would win that trip
and you just win this trip to Spain and
it's worth eight thousand seven hundred
sixty seven dollars and I'm like oh my
god like I'm never gonna be able to go
to Spain because I'm never gonna drop
nine thousand dollars on a trip like wow
how lucky are they to win that right but
you know now with the technology we have
in the tools we have you can do that
from a fraction of what what people
typically think it takes right to get
out of their city and get somewhere else
it's a non-traditional route I mean you
talked about couchsurfing we met a whole
bunch of people while we were doing our
first tour who lent their houses out to
couch surfers and people we met a lot of
people on couchsurfing yeah and what we
realized is like oh there are are these
unconventional ways to do this that if
you can't afford the traditional way you
can still explore these places so if
you're looking for a place to move it's
not about finding the city that's
perfect for you it's about maybe testing
two three or four or five of them out
for committing to living there for a
month or a year or the rest of your life
all right let's move on the right here
right now so we talk about what's going
on in the lives of the minimalists my
partner Rebecca is starting a back up
her 23-day priorities reset over at
minimal wellness comm she's a registered
dietician and a nutritionist and also
extremely extremely healthy and fit she
always takes thirty people at a time and
those tend to sell out but the October
one is coming up so if you're interested
in that it's just minimal wellness comm
I wrote down here send flowers this is
something we've been doing with the
minimalists ryan recently we've just had
a few people reach out to us on social
media so I've had Jess send some flowers
to them like not everyone you can't do
this with everyone but I what I've
realized like it feels good to do this
once a month where if someone had that
their boyfriend died or someone else
their mother died and it's just like hey
I'm sorry to hear about hear about that
I see you here's a here's a nice note
that alright for them and maybe give
them a little bit of insight maybe I've
gone through a similar experience and
what I'm going to encourage other people
to do this could even be part of the
added value segment is send flowers
whenever you can try it out once a month
you talked about contributing to your
community
that's one way you can do it be there
for someone when they need the help and
quite often where we try to contribute
when people don't need it and then we
miss out on the opportunities when
someone really does need it so sending
flowers to folks is inexpensive way to
show someone look I I see you and I care
speaking of caring we've talked about
the Jim City Market we're over let's say
we're over forty thousand dollars raised
for the Jim City market right now by end
of the year we want to get to a hundred
thousand dollars to help build this
grocery co-op in Dayton Ohio the west
side of Dayton has 40 percent of the
population and zero grocery stores let's
get to $100,000 if you want to help us
out with that any amount of money you
can donate a dollar twenty dollars fifty
dollars whatever you can do will help
out immensely go to the minimalists comm
slash Dayton to contribute we were in
Brazil this past week now it's time to
talk about Brazil now it's thought that
was so such a great trip dude like I
have never seen a city as been it was
like Mexico City is was our connecting
flight right in like flying in there
like oh man Mexico City is I mean it
just puts LA to shame but then you get
to sell Paulo the density and it's like
even more dense it was what an awesome
experience man like thanks so much to
the folks out there at sa P who like
brought us out there and yeah so what an
awesome group of people we gave this
keynote talk at the SA P conference in
the conference we had this a 30 second
surprise like right beforehand neither
one and we - I haven't talked about this
yet but right as we were getting ready
to go on stage Alex the sound guy he was
like by the way only five percent of
Brazilians speak English fluently and
we're getting ready go out on stage and
give a 45 minute talk and no one
bothered to tell us that 95 percent of
the audience did not speak English
fluently now thankfully well that mean
just that what Alex said was is yes five
percent of Brazilians speak English as
well as he does he said you're probably
gonna see a lot of the five percent here
right but yet but they had translators
right
assuming they translate but I didn't
know that at first I mean I learned
Portuguese just in case yeah there were
people were in headphones that so they
were trash let's talk about that real
quick yeah so the whole idea behind this
conference I don't know what you would
call it a forum yeah a forum is they
would have several talks going on at
once yeah in the same room different
stages 20 different talks at once
sometimes and what you did is it was a
silent conference so you wore these
headphones and then you would be like oh
I want to hear these people talk so I'm
gonna switch to Channel four and then
all of a sudden you can hear them giving
their talk now I'm assuming is a little
weird because you have like you'd be
listening to you know stage number three
and then at stage number two right next
to you like they start clapping or
something and yeah maybe a little bit
distracting but it made me think of the
silent discos that I've seen a lot in
Europe where you basically wear
headphones and you can pick you know
between a couple different channels and
if you didn't have headphones on and you
were looking into the room there's just
a bunch of people dancing to different
be different looking crazy but then as
soon as you put the headphones and
you're like oh like now I get it
and you can see which people are dancing
the same yeah and then what was
fascinating is they opened up the whole
when we gave the keynote they opened up
sort of the whole conference to just our
talk so there are 20 different stages
around so people were watching our
there's 5,000 people there they're
watching us sort of they're they'll be
in this room watching our talk or the
you know a thousand people in front of
us are watching it they're 2,000
whatever it was but then there's being
broadcast on the other stage and there's
people on the watching us on a TV on the
other stage as well it was like her
biggest crowd today right what was like
5,000 yeah having 5,000 people I've
never spoken directly to 5,000 people
just a couple thousand and so what was
really nice about about Brazil's is
again going back to the people and the
people we met I mean they could not have
been friendlier will definitely make it
back to Brazil to do a proper tour stop
sometime in the future but it was
wonderful yeah I finally gave myself
permission to have fun at the at that
conference because I'm like all right oh
yeah it's gonna be like this is gonna be
difficult because we're going out here I
didn't realize they didn't all speak
English
forget it I'm just gonna have as much
fun as I can on stage and it worked it's
so funny because like you know we'll be
given a talk and you know sometimes
which this was the case in Sao Paulo
it's like we're given the talk great the
delivery is good and like I know it's
good yeah
hitting hitting it but like the people
are giving you the reactions that you're
kind of looking for but every culture is
different and also the translation
barrier
long story short though like that was it
was it was such a wonderful event I
would do that all over again
afterward and they were like crazy happy
about I'm like oh you were yeah you see
the photo the picture i photo bombed on
Instagram no oh dude someone had tagged
it was when we were getting in the car
or bulletproof car that day I think they
give us a bulletproof ladder went out of
their way make sure is that to make sure
we were safe
at night and I could not appreciate that
more I mean I truly am thankful for that
it's the first time I've ever been
mobbed like we were many inversions of
the beetle like kind of the Beatles like
people were coming out to the our
bulletproof car so we were taking that
picture with a group of people outside
of the car yeah and I was already in the
backseat but like I popped out and
totally put it on Instagram but uh but
yeah you know just going back to the
whole thing we're feeling that
trepidation of the city and being
dangerous yeah like I really did have
this this moment the other day walking
well it was when we came back from Sao
Paulo so yeah just the other day walking
in Hollywood I was very nervous walking
through Hollywood because well dude we
were walking to that concert and like
we're coming up on Cahuenga and a sunset
which is a nice area and we crossed the
street not like there's this cop who
pulled these two guys over and all of a
sudden we hear gun back up back up he's
got a gun and then we look over and the
dudes got their their their guns drawn
you've got you know we started running
you me and Mariah started running
towards the the venue which was really
weird because we were the only ones
running away if you notice everyone else
at that time was going towards yes the
chaos which blows my Matt's back to the
acting versus reacting like like I was
acting I want to get out like what's
going on let's see what are these cops
got their guns out
I get a selfie with this person who's
getting into a fight with the cop within
three minutes there's a helicopter
swarming above the the you know the
scene there are like at least you can
you could see half a dozen here another
dozen cops I mean it was this is this is
a reason to give me a little bit of
trepidation walking around Hollywood but
what I realized the other day especially
coming from Sao Paulo
mmm is that if I keep to myself if I
avoid you know the dangerous areas as
much as I can and and just really be
smart when it comes to when I walk
around where I walk around and you know
so forth and so on
chances aren't probably gonna be okay
yeah and and and that um I don't know
man I don't I don't know why this is
such a huge breakthrough for me but like
I was just explaining this to Mariah
yesterday when we were we were walking
to get some groceries or something and I
was just explaining to her like you know
probably life my life our lives are not
going to be in danger as long as we are
smart as long as we are you know
deliberate and it's the South Powell
really helped me see that because yeah
it's a dangerous city and if you go to
the wrong place at the wrong time you
know if you're not keeping your wits
about you like that city is not a city
for beginners yeah and but of course the
same can be true and virtually and he
said you go - right exactly are gonna
find the wrong people if you're looking
for the wrong people we're not not
looking out for the wrong people then
yeah you can end up in a world of hurt
whether you're in Orlando or Brooklyn or
Dayton or or Missoula or wherever like
you can end up in the wrong place and
and if you're not doing it intentionally
then yeah you could be in for a world of
hurt a couple new writings on our
website we have the 1 in 10 out rule I
won't explain that to you but you'll
figure it out stuff on our website right
now and also the rule of two the rule of
two it's a new essay up on the website
you can find those over at the
minimalists com and also if you want to
get new essays new minimalism rules new
podcast show notes as well you can sign
up for our email list over at the
minimalists comm will never send you any
spam because if you wanted to spam you'd
probably go by it yourself
oh and
had a few people ask about this so I
figured I'd at least talk about it real
quick on the podcast while you're
waiting for our second you're waiting
patiently for our second film to come
out you can watch six hours of bonus
footage from our documentary minimalism
a lot of you are already seen it but
those six hours of bonus footage are
available only at minimalism film calm I
think it's ten dollars if you want to
buy the six hours of bonus interviews
it's basically all the interviews that
we had in the documentary but extended
versions some of them didn't even make
not even appeared right in the
documentary but some really awesome
interviews right they didn't fit into
the narrative documentary but they're
good standalone interviews Andy Davis is
one that sticks out there quite a few
people drew you know did the soundtrack
to the film there's six hours of
additional footage bonus interviews you
can get over at minimalism film calm and
what else do I have here oh if you want
to comment on this episode you can do so
over at youtube youtube.com slash the
minimalists and we'll just remind you
like we are we band people pretty freely
so if you don't want to be in our house
you don't have to it's a safe space for
you to comment to if you're absolutely
wood commenter then that's a great place
to go conversation absolutely
hi Ryan you got anything else for us
yeah man I got some voicemail tips and
tricks from our listeners you want to
check them out let's do it all right
hey Ryan and Josh my name is Suzanne and
I'm from Munich Germany and have a tip
for all the fashionistas who want to
have a minimalist but regularly updated
or drug my friends and I have been doing
clothing swap parties a couple of times
now we meet up at one of our places and
everyone brings clothes she or he
doesn't like or wear anymore we just
play the items like in a shop create a
small changing room and then everyone
tries on and takes home whatever he or
she likes that way you do not spend any
money get rid of old items and give them
a new home where they can add more value
and you also get new clothes for free
plus you can try them on first and can
be 100 percent sure they will fit and
look good hi Josh and Ryan this is
Desmond from Las Vegas I'm calling in
with a tip for your listeners if they
are anything like me some may be
obsessed with clearing the notifications
or having a zero inbox this includes the
tiny red circle that pops up on the
iPhone apps in the top left corner with
the number of unread messages after
constantly deleting and reinstalling my
work apps to eliminate my distractions I
happen to go into my settings which is
where I found a solution in settings
once you have clicked on the app go to
the notifications in the middle of the
screen you will see a switch that says
badge app icon once you turn it off
those little annoying circles are gone
and the numbers are gone with them and
you can use your phone with one less
distraction
hello Joe Shenron my name is Alana from
Melbourne Australia so I have a tip for
parents who struggle to deal with toys
for their kids in Australia we have two
libraries where you can borrow those
like books in the usual libraries there
is a small annual fee that lets you
borrow a few toys for your children
every week or so and there is a lot of
toys to choose from I believe something
similar exists in US and other countries
so it might be worth looking into in
your area that can save parents a lot of
money and storage space as well as late
in a child to learn the life of access
instead of excess all right Joe that's
it for this episode if you have a
question for the minimalists give us a
call for zero six two one nine seven
eight three nine you can also email at
voice memo to podcast at the minimalists
comm oh and before we tell you how to
leave here Ryan I want before we give
you the last line our friend Austin
Hartley Leonard has one of my favorite
songs and I like to play anytime I go
back to Dayton or any go back to Ohio so
I think figured Shawn if we can in this
episode if you listen to the audio
version of it you'll get to hear Ohio by
our friend Austin Hartley Leonard is one
of my top five favorite songs it's a
great whole time I just got to hang out
with him in Nashville recently but it's
a great song in the podcast with that
and if you're watching on YouTube then
we'll just put a I don't know maybe
there's a link or something Jordan you
can you can find because we can't play
other people's music that we don't own
on YouTube
alright show off you all leave here
today with just one message we hope it's
this love people and use things because
the opposite never works thanks for
listening y'all we'll see you next time
[Music]
minimus